the las vegas metropolitan police
department foundation the sponsors of
this next segment have officially
brought their online store to life
inside the fashion show mall rocky
stopped by to check it out
hey tom hey rocky how are you i'm good
how are you thanks for coming by oh of
course i couldn't wait to see it because
this is your very first lvmpd
brick and mortar store you guys have
already have your online store but this
is your first one that people can come
to and shop too physically right that's
right so for a few years we've been
selling merchandise online and we
decided that we wanted to have a
brick-and-mortar presence because people
wanted to see what the stuff was all
about uh take a look at it in person uh
and we were getting a lot of questions
we thought well let's help them out yeah
give me a place to go try it on and then
there are a lot of people that don't
know we exist exactly this gives us a
great way to be in front of all the
visitors to las vegas and a lot of
locals who come to the mall definitely
so introduce us to the lvmpd foundation
what do you guys do so the lvmpd
foundation exists to provide important
funding for the police department in
public safety we fund everything from a
college scholarship program for the
children of officers
to health and wellness programming for
our officers and their families
to important technology and equipment
and we're building a new reality-based
training center for the department that
will open this year very cool very cool
so i guess now the next thing we got to
do is go through these items so we can
shop that sounds great
where should we start so let's start
with our uh probably our most important
item of course the dogs right hang on
everybody's doing this every year right
we do this every year we create a canine
calendar uh that features uh
the different
dogs of uh
metro all right what else do we have of
course i see the house
definitely getting one of these
excellent that's our most popular item
this is not just a local thing tourists
come to shop here as well yes in fact
probably the majority of our buyers
right now are tourists because we
haven't got the word that you know to
locals that this exists yeah well that's
why
that's why we're here now you have my
eye on this on this one you want to try
it on yeah let's do it all right
thank you oh and it's comfortable
okay
yep you've got those we've got a couple
different types blue black with the
badge and then uh a lot of civilians
don't know about challenge coins yeah
what about the police departments across
the country put these uh together uh to
commemorate their work and they give
them out or in our case we're selling
them as a way to raise money for the
foundation i'll get this one too thank
you perfect
and i hear that you guys have a discount
for local law enforcement as well it's
actually for all law enforcement so
whether you're visiting in your law
enforcement or you live here inner law
enforcement it's a 15 discount that is
great that is great appreciation for
your service absolutely and how else can
we as a community support or as a nation
i should say support the lvmpd
foundation well the best way is to go to
our website
lvmpdfoundation.org
there we list all the different ways you
can support you can make a gift online
you can attend one of our many events
wow well thank you to the lvmpd
foundation for supporting those who keep
us safe every day well thank you for
being here rocky we really appreciate it
all right now i gotta i gotta buy this
stuff i'm supporting thank you
thank you to the las vegas metropolitan
police department foundation for
sponsoring that segment you can visit
their kiosk at the fashion show mall or
give them a call at
702-983-7369 or head to
lvmpdfoundation.org and remember as a
show of appreciation the store offers a
15 percent discount for any in-person
purchase for law enforce